miss ja ja Gabor
those nominated for the best best
achievement in costume design black and
white are kind lady metro-goldwyn-mayer
bought a blanket and God healed the
model and the marriage broker 20 Century
Fox Charles de mer and Rene the mudlark
20th century father Edward Stevenson and
Margot pure a place in the sand
Kurama Edith Head a streetcar named
desire Charles K Feldman group
production Warner Brothers Lucinda
Bernard young village the veena is Edith
this is going to be an old walk for
either head even head into the head of
the costume design pharmacy oh I'm sorry
we talked over you sweet nothings but it
was simply thank you so much those
nominated for the best achievement in
costume design kala are an American in
Paris métro doll be male or Akeley
water planchet and iron shadow David and
Bathsheba 20th Century Fox Chara mayor
Edward Stevenson the great Caruso
metro-goldwyn-mayer Helen rose and God
steel kavadi metro-goldwyn-mayer Hershel
McCoy tears of Hoffmann a micro Powell
and Emeric Pressburger production no but
film contribution cooperation British
Hein heckler young the Venus orry-kelly
more the Plunkett and iron chair
is an American parent the Oscar would be
accepted by water faucet who twice
previously as benign
costume design
sighs woman were bulky here is mr.
Plunkett at the microphone Julie this is
the most unexpected surprise I thank you
for myself I thank you for orry-kelly
and I thank you for Irene sheriff and I
also think Irene sheriff because I think
some of her inspired and wonderful work
is the only reason I have this thank you
very very much
you ready job but don't worry Finn
anything